meriem binette à 55 ans la ménopause a
eu l'effet d'une tornade dans sa vie
c'est pas juste une faiblesse c'est
aussi l'insomnie ça patine aussi le
moindre résistance
elle a essayé l'hormonothérapie mais
sans succès elle travaille cinq à six
jours par semaine
mais là davantage besoin de se reposer
c'est davantage que j'ai d'être
propriétaire est d'avoir une équipe
extraordinaire qui travaillent avec moi
ce qui me permet de pouvoir me prendre
travaillez beaucoup un certain temps
puis prendre trois semaines de vacances
dans sa loge m'évade dans ma maison et
de la madeleine je pensais jusqu'à 65
travaillé dans un cabinet d'avocats être
efficace être tout le temps la [ __ ] en
tablier on doit s'abstenir
depuis que les baies nos pauses et
sylvie lefebvre dort beaucoup moins bien
c'est l'une des raisons qui l'a poussé à
devenir travailleuse autonome qu'elle
peut désormais faire une sieste l'après
midi est-ce que pas trop motorisera à 2
heures 3 heures de l'après midi de faire
une sieste de 20 minutes
brown a comme on appelle pour pouvoir
recharger la batterie
la question de la ménopause en milieu de
travail est devenu un véritable enjeu en
grande bretagne la chaîne de télévision
britannique channel four vient
d'annoncer qu'elle offrira désormais des
horaires flexibles et des congés de
maladie payés aux employés ménopausées
qui en ont besoin
s'il est élu aux prochaines élections le
parti travailliste s'engage même à
obliger les grandes entreprises à
incommoder les travailleuses ménopausées
je pense qu'effectivement on est rendu à
une étape de la société où on n'aura pas
le choix de réfléchir aux femmes dans
cette situation là parce que c'est
vraiment le bordel maso me 7,8
d'hormones à ce gynécologue obstétricien
affirme que la diminution des estrogènes
et de la progestérone entraîne des
symptômes chez 50 à 70% des femmes mais
des symptômes sévères ce à peu près une
dizaine
dix pour cent de la population
essentiellement c'est les bouffées de
chaleur l'histoire la nuit avec des
douleurs articulaires et puis après dit
à tout le laisse faire des changements
d'humeur résultat d'une vie en société
une réalité encore tabou est essentiel
c'est d'en parler de manière à
sensibiliser de manière à ce que les
entreprises puissent intégrer cela dans
leurs meilleures pratiques
caroline codes dits crois qu'il faut
sensibiliser les employeurs à la
question mais pas de là les fait rire
c'est un tabou qu'on veut lever mais ça
reste délicat tout simplement parce que
je ne veux pas qu'on se trouve des
excuses supplémentaire pour dire que
voilà pourquoi on n'a pas choisi une
femme elle est ménopausée
le débat ne s'est pas encore transporté
jusqu'au québec
mais invité à réagir le ministre du
travail jean boulet affirme que les
entreprises doivent mettre en place des
mesures d'accommodement pour ces
travailleuses surtout avec la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre actuelle ici marie-eve
cousineau raid au canada montréal